yeah spontaneous livestream I figured
I'm having my morning coffee and I might
as well just play some games while doing
it that won't be all that long they have
to do some stuff later but if I play
some games
do it do it like that why not so let's
see um let's see what could it into can
I do here like a tournament our only
bullet arena maybe there are these super
blitz yeah why not let's go for the
hourly super blitz and join not yet
featured and I don't have a viewer at
least that's what this tells me know
what Sima
I'm not going to berserk every game or
something like that yeah good morning to
all of you in the chat some of the view
account doesn't block it seems I screwed
up ahead I could have played aged 5
already you made this mistake with
castling funny ever decay you have to
have to get get into the playing mode
first yet before as we care right I've
got everybody looking at that
yeah Sega's chess it's not moving I hope
that connection is fine or is that what
is going on here or maybe he just
doesn't know what to do here it's
possible yeah good morning to all of you
in the chat chair now he really took
this long time okay that's that's good
it took on c6 which is yeah not the move
you want to play but I kind of
understand
so h3 I'm installing hey let's say this
pawn right in the middle of White's
position so I'm going to go for night
age form I don't know is that actually
that great for me hmm I don't know it's
not that clear right it's not that clear
huh I don't like my position all that
much to be honest now that I look at it
I mean it is always tricky but this was
actually stupid movie 91 is coming
anyway it wasn't great yeah there wasn't
a good idea whenever I played he was not
great I think I was a ticking deform
yeah the thing is mm yeah it's a way for
me I can I can go look be aged here
maybe a rook b8 temple it's looking at
this pawn awesome it's a way for me to
get something going
I need I need some development my bad
bishop here c5 is not good all says
shall be three on the cards for me not
and it's not great
it can take C yeah I thought you would
take it I don't know that looks very
scary
somebody is hosting my stream okay yeah
I actually have no clue what that means
I'm I came across this hosting stuff but
I read about it but I have no clue what
it actually means
what is that position sucks
my queen has really no squares just
Bishop b2 a that will give him a strong
attack I'm very sure about it yeah yeah
and he's also taking it's attacking g7
and okay after I have to do this the
only thing that keeps my position
somewhat alive ah I can't go Queen c6
and we should be seven something like
that could be tricky
I mean this is the the benefit of the
pawn on h3 it's definitely going to be
tricky
okra d8 is almost made you can play this
Queenie a tactic 9006 will be made okay
this is chick
maybe I'm not shake lated immediately at
least Quan f6 again that's no made I
think d7 is a square we should see four
check now on the cards or queen subform
I have to check if to play the rook yeah
and I have one all time wow that was
pretty terrible pretty terrible yeah
it's it's a late start to this zone I
might want to observe the odd game
Margit APRI desaturating is good 5 mm no
it's not so bad let's see I can just
develop Queen on f3 is a bit odd but not
much that I can do about it maybe he
maybe he wants to cast along let's see
probably not so um yeah this is going to
be annoying that was one idea a5 a4 just
pin him here um yeah I can do that
[Music]
just be be a pain here to do this yeah
and this is quite nice I think with this
pin let's go Queen g5 cannot castle
short yeah maybe this is I was just
thinking I could he could castle long
and he did this is not too bad yeah the
worst is over here with our storm
warning yeah it's a good move I probably
probably not but I want to have some
easy moves to play so let's try to just
open it up yeah thanks for them feedback
max Quincy 4 runs into Bishop d2 check
it is important ok m9 h6 or what's the
point
like I just tried to trade this it
should be a good idea it says protective
bishop let's say okay
and cannot be bad it cannot be so bad I
wonder about Drago age five what what
happens here isn't he just losing the
night
no no no snow squares I don't get to
swing to the edge fire all that quickly
Alice's stop done I rather want to trap
the night yeah I happy to check oh you
cannot play Knight F to do two Queen
takes you three anyway now III is
hanging okay so he resigned I'm getting
closer here how much like wow eight
points behind that won't be so easy look
a one was made in - yeah King D - yeah
hey possible it's only it's really early
on
okay a Scandinavian c5 really that looks
weird
- give me all of that space him now
that's all for now I'm going to check
here it should be five I take on f7 and
Janet also not nice him threatening
Queen takes six which is ignored okay I
mean it's just a trade young Queen e7
and we've just trading stuff and I'm a
pawn up
yeah install the donations yesterday and
it worked there already have been some
during the titled turn on stream that's
26 I've got the much better development
him
we should see four check keep that on
the board I would like to yeah I don't
think I can prevent him from developing
97 I cannot really prevent okay now I
prevent 97 and that can get ugly a
knight cannot move let's keep it like
that that the only goal in that's not
allow him to move any of his pieces and
care to as a move I should avoid yeah
that would be pretty ugly
stumbling 290 form
[Music]
I'm not in much of a hurry Hanna okay
this is also pretty neat no this this
way actually gets to move it
hah I always looked at hmm okay I mean
it still still very nice very nice
but still I did not did not take that
into account
huh carcasses you bought my book last
week a thank you I hope you enjoy it and
it's helpful
yeah just move its two pawns and the
bishop has this ideal position on deform
the my name is iboga book it's a
repeater book on the name is Owen Bob
Union it was released in 20 2015
yeah I window night so that I won't
blunder the H pong it's easier it's not
going to resign I'm still mate
okay would be helpful actually if they
would resign stuff like that to catch up
yeah I'm basically two games behind s
Giga Rijn that's for me first time
nothing hmm
okay 35 minutes
mmm okay maybe I need to be Zerg a game
or get a game first morphine um can
observe that I'm going you're going to
try
[Music]
yeah this is a funny line yeah but but I
think white is better here a g4 move
looks a bit strange but it is some
ultimately a good space advantage so
take on d5 and I would like some time to
consider this but I don't have it I
don't have the time unfortunately
yeah this f/4g for it's not super nice
in a bullet game which it is basically
here with this time because yeah your
king position is just going to be weak
but yeah it's what it is
f6 now I guess f6 and 44 castles you
know this is kind of what I have to do
at least in this format I'd like to keep
things a little bit organized
yeah and I'm better here but my king
position is wide open
yeah I've got all kinds of pins going on
you yes now time to move but it would be
nice to get in like b-58 for a 5 take
everything and then promote the a pawn
that would be nice man it's possible
maybe he has to make a move here in the
first place
not so easy and the time ticks down
[Music]
we're getting close
everything traded and the apron would
promote but he won't trade and trade
everything anyhow
King is seven maybe and I go Queenie
form for Queen to be seven it's quite
annoying queen g6 is also possible and
wait okay yeah it was a big area with
them with the open King yeah I see big
arenas just scoring him huh
I need to get paired with him that would
be would be helpful okay oops not very
quick here this is a tricky line black
is like it's just better not if you're
not blunder like I do ah crap
i blunder the freaking piece him oh my
god against this near always hate to
lose against silly lines like that it is
just a bad line for white a blunder
piece yeah white is completely running
completely winning oh my god that is
that is totally sick if
yeah and the problem is I mean besides
being completely lost that's also
totally easy to play I mean it's almost
impossible to screw up it's got a five
coming here I don't know my fire is
completely deadly five
no man he five just wins of course and
that might win as well he's got this
chick coming no that was the tournament
how idiotic I was playing too quickly
oh okay yeah I took on a three far too
quickly
well that lets um the problem sometimes
that I have with the berserk I'm getting
into getting into into this rushed kind
of mindset and then I get into trouble
it's 9:30 in the morning here okay the
only chance for some really quick
berserk wins
a good thing that I didn't remove
anything here so let's see
can I put up at least a bit of a fight
him and get some some wins every also I
mean it always annoys me even in these
time controls to lose against such a
terrible opening just by playing too
quickly now it cannot challenge me and
this year I may I want to by playing
this tournament and after that I'm
stopping the stream adjuster to extreme
while I have my morning coffee I have to
leave after that going for need to run
to the to the supermarket get some stuff
for the weekend or actually blunder this
I'm not doing this doing this quickly
I'm really not yeah the storm is okay
again there's nothing
it is it is countdown
I'm just going to checkmated me I don't
think you can prevent that anymore it's
a bit much here yeah I can't I cannot
catch up
probably anyhow where it's just four
points oh yes most one okay okay then
there are chances just pair me with this
person here that would help okay do a
berserk that happens far too often today
come on let her play 96 they're
basically bye-bye pre moving come on
yeah this is okay and to quickly reroute
to g6 and okay not happy about taking
but I have to okay wow he gives me a
very strong Bishop now on c5 if that is
surprising so let's sit civi can
irritate him here with 9 th for and some
trickery
no I don't think I have to what you said
I don't think afters possibility I don't
want to take him I had played age six
right we should shift five no no I
didn't have it f2 was covered and then I
looked at this f2 was covered okay well
let that should be fine for me check
here so maybe some age five stuff age
five you cannot take it and if he goes
g5 I go here intending Knight g3 yeah
okay hmm I have to go back that's not
good and age four okay 37 seconds I
should not forget that I am in berserk
mode here I'm just having my morning
coffee
mm-hmm why so early he was asked and I
felt why not play a stream I was
actually thinking of establishing this
format yeah because yeah I'm going to
have him more coffee in the morning
anyway why not play the game while
having it check check
mate
okay I'm closing in I'm closing in
somewhat somewhat yeah Internet is
better I don't know it was probably due
to the storm or something probably the
combination of server load and and the
problems related to the weather
let's go inform the other good old
French exchange yeah I analyze this this
recently people actually made fun of me
for doing that
but I really think it is not that easy
for black in some cases so let's see if
black manages to equalize here or not
just going to double the file and claim
that I will always be somewhat better in
this case
yeah III know what you what you mean him
I was a statement that he cannot that
you cannot play a game early in the
morning yeah I always had problems with
that so it seemed I see no point I will
97 now that that will trade a bit more
even mmm I did not want that to happen
okay okay I'm trying to take this it's a
little bit unusual maybe there also
isn't good young and I was stupid I was
thinking he cannot easily play of six
but of course he can okay that is a good
ending it could be tricky with buzzer
King it to be honest it's it's very
comfortable but that is not rookie it's
not a good move but Knight age five now
I cannot cover this yeah it said a we
know not yeah if I go further I'm not
sure it is a win but he has no good move
here yes no good move I'm just stepping
up to a form now I can go into the king
of porn ending
and let's fit forces you don't want to
have this prenup on the whole time so
the deep pond will do with the job okay
yes actually overtook him I only gets
two points after the after the street
was was chopped so medium this is
something that I should do without
buzzer King okay it's a bit different
what is different yeah I haven't I
haven't played Bishop a7 huh okay I
don't know if this is a big difference
I mean I know that I'm good just go into
fire anyway I'm not sure I'd like to get
over to the kingside so 97 and night
comes to f5 also in some cases no that's
okay so let's go here against g4 I have
h3 it's very awkward to play before I
take on g3 let's go into it Turkey
Bishop h1 h2 check
Kinji - yeah yeah I even have Queen
takes g5 which could be interesting but
I think taking as good and just leading
to an advantage he's got yeah I mean
this is a good move but he's got Luke h1
coming just kind of unfortunate that he
gets us in
hmm it's kind of okay here that it was
well defended you offended this really
well I cannot do that okay
it has very well played by white the
tech is extremely dangerous and he
managed to defend it and it's got Queen
age for men
what's going on here I'm completely lost
Wow
I don't believe this stuff
who the heck is solar Jim defending this
perfectly and I takes is terrible
actually
yeah don't believe it I mean this this
opening is extremely dangerous and he
plays like perfect defense or what what
did I do wrong here I don't quite get it
isn't that a good position for me huh
okay anyway now I don't think you
cheated no no I just played terribly
probably oh wow heck so named okay oh I
get paired with him that's nice so at
least I can catch up I just played badly
them I think so I should better beat
this guy down to fourth place him like
right from the lead you drop back and
now he plays my opening either the four
nights just being boring
a three and witness is what is going on
here
it's weird
hey you three
hmm that is a very weird way of playing
for someone who leads a tournament
Bishop h6 moon okay it is really yeah
the cc's of course playing playing the
opening like a complete beginner but now
it sees every single move here and it's
a new yeah yeah okay we know what the
deal oh my goodness
yeah just bend this guy
yeah just ninja I mean yeah you see that
like immediately yeah it takes time for
most obvious move plays of course a
completely terrible opening to just yeah
make fun of people then you also you
know it's kind of pointless you see he
played a complete crap at the beginning
yeah and then and then he won like six
games yeah the middle of nowhere I don't
know what people what white people do
that and it's just so pointless it's so
pointless and a complete waste of time
whenever I am doing something good with
their lives yeah cheating in online
chess is so pointless I mean it is also
pointless to cheat in other forms of
chess but I mean like what what's the
deal what's the deal I don't get it
can you please bend us if somebody is
listening in with an admin account of
leeches I mean it's like so obvious him
also I mean they they know that people
will recognize it's just like extremely
obvious
yeah observed to this game I mean I mean
I think I almost had this tournament in
the bag but now the one bad game and the
cheetah game is too much I'm just going
for a check here on the side of the
board she preparing night before maybe
yeah my queenís is wrong there on h4 if
I want to checkmate here and I have to
get the Queen over yeah he only switched
the engine on later yeah he didn't cheat
the whole tournament the first games
that he lost there were they were human
errors is also the DM who is kind of
staggering and they they they they or
they usually play some completely
terrible opening to rub it in or maybe
they don't know better and then they let
the engine play the rest it's it's
really weird okay
yeah well I'm I'm venturing away here
about cheating this position isn't all
that great actually at least I get a
good night on to e5 that's that's a good
part and this is a really huge fork yeah
I did buzzer this so I have to hurry up
a5 maybe a play
very good
that would exchange up so let's push a
Jeep on there's no way to stop it
yeah six minutes left has no chance to I
mean okay that that person's winning of
the tournament would be banned off his
name but yeah this is still a problem I
think with with the cheating detection
and banning actually works quite well I
mean yeah like it works well on the
chess it works well on chess calm for
example but the thing is I mean you can
only bend after they cheat so I mean
they they like win the tournament and
and you annoy it and you can only bend
them afterwards of course so you kind of
had this bad experience already so okay
that was a way and I'm still five points
behind the cheatin the Cabrero has he's
on pause yeah I don't know maybe they
maybe they can bend him in the middle of
it no I did not see the airplanes
landing in the midst of the storm this
is crazy sometimes and what they what
they have to do when when they have this
bad weather and it's not promoters
okay III is not really necessary here
playing fast swerve or fun 12
so got a fairly slow position going on
it's probably roughly equal I'd like to
play a for him
prepare for he's got some problems with
the noid actually 97 f5 there's some
problems there yeah it's not so my
position is a bit loose and the night
only five would be quite strong so it's
not not the easiest win ever let's say
94 still on the cards him hmm
how do I do that step out of this chest
step out of the night shakes prepare
Knight f3 he goes back again I go back
again and then I need to improve maybe
do something active night cheeks that
was that helpful I don't know he's
spinning himself
got some pressure on you five now you
had Queen f24 come I don't know maybe
and queen g6 queen e8 is set as queen f8
but this is this is leading to maid yep
and now we turn off the engine ha oh my
god you're killing me you're killing me
now give me that guy again yeah and yes
the engine turned off oh my goodness
yeah I would need a really quick win now
all right so maybe it's difficult to get
a club winning with this and I can't
rhyme black is not in good shape here
I know d6 was hanging but I need to win
with made I can take 95 that's actually
not that bad yeah okay he takes b2 or
something
Queen b6 yeah I should have taken on d6
that that was just a poor simply winning
but but I wanted to try to win by made
and now I'm in trouble
Queen to b6 is still a good move it was
the whole time it's pointless
that's a funny question if I ever have
sang a song one stream no I didn't so
and you don't want me to do that I
assure you
does that actually count or something
okay I'm going to resign it yeah so this
cheetah idiot wonder won the event he
will be banned eventually but what can
you do
okay guys I need to stop the stream I
have to run now for my for my
supermarket trip going to go grocery
shopping for the weekend I hope you
enjoyed the quick stream here early in
the morning at least my time and I'm
yeah back soon
at least I'll be on Monday but I will be
on the earlier thanks a lot bye bye guys